circle any point on the um on the
circumference
you've got center this is where it's
rotating around so i put theta there
i've i've drawn the arrow as well to
indicate which is actually kind of
important oh i'm missing something i'm
missing a line
um to indicate the direction of motion
because i'm thinking angular velocity
and kind of anticlockwise is our default
okay just like on the unit circle
um i've got this distance which is two
so i've just
popped it there because it's useful all
right so what do we need to work out
two questions for this first part
firstly angular velocity
at a and angular velocity at b
okay so what's going on let's do a first
a is not so hard i think you saw that so
this is the angle i'm after
in here okay so you can see that
this angle that i'm after it's standing
on the same arc
that this angle is on except this is the
center and this is at the
circumference okay so all you need to
say is i guess i would say
um p a b
that's going to give me the angular
velocity a right is equal to
theta on two and of course your reason
for that is angle at the center
is twice the angle of the circumference
standing on the same arc etc
okay since it's theta on two
therefore because theta and don't forget
right this theta dot notation
dot is just differentiate with respect
to time
yeah okay so they're just trying to um
it's just a shortcut way of writing it
just like we're used to x dot and y dot
etc okay so if this is
what that angle is equal to right then
clearly this is
changing right so in other words theta
is a function of time
right so but this angle is changing at
half the rate of this angle
right so if theta dots pi radians per
second
and this angle is always exactly half of
theta
right therefore the
rate of change here or the angular
velocity i should say
the angular velocity at a should be
equal to
pi rates per second or two can you just
do that okay
yeah yeah you can okay um because if you
think about it
like okay one second passes right um
actually sorry
start again where's where's a place for
it to begin maybe maybe here
okay and then it starts to go around the
circle around the circle
so where is it after one second um
well it's gonna it's gonna have gone
halfway around
okay so actually your angle here will be
that's not such a good example because
i'm actually going to be at a
i think so let's think about half a
second okay half a second
so at half a second i which is actually
a good one i'm going to need that later
at half a second i'm going to have
started here and i'll be up here at pion
2.
okay so there's my theta what will
what will my angle at a be equal to and
you can see you're going to have
isosceles isosceles a right angle
clearly it's going to be pine four in
the corner right which is what you
expected
so in half a second this has moved pi on
two
and in half a second this has moved pi
over four
right which is a rate of pi on two
radians per second
okay so this angle is completely
dependent
on this angle here right and it's
changing at half the rate that this
angle is changing
so yes you can just say it all right
you've got to be careful and the next
angle i'll show you why okay
so let's have a look now at the next one
i want to work out what's happening at b
okay so i've written here this is theta
on two okay now i have some angles here
right
um see the angle at p
no matter where p is on the circle the
angle at p
because it's the angle in a semicircle
will be
pi on two radians okay so
this is tricky to get right this is
variable this
is variable this is not variable this is
pi on two
and it's always pi on two okay so now
when i'm working out an angle like say
this one right how do i work out
how do i calculate that well it's in a
triangle right
but you've got to be careful it's in a
triangle with a variable angle
and a not variable angle okay so you
have to make sure you don't
confuse those with each other right so
if i want to work out just
angle um p b a
okay i should i suppose i should do it
as a proper sum of the angles on the
triangle
right so i've got that theta on 2 over
there plus
pi on two now this does this changes
this doesn't change
that's going to be equal to pi yeah okay
because of the angle sum of that
triangle yeah
so so far so good now i want to know
what's
what's that angle that's the angle i'm
after just like i was after it here
right so when you take everything over
to the
right side that'll become pi on two
minus
theta on two okay so
what part of this is changing and the
answer is
this part is changing this part is not
changing
right therefore the angular velocity
which is about
change right at b depends solely on this
part
right so um this is constant
this is the part that's changing which
represents velocity so it should be
um minus theta on two but theta
it's change its rate of change its
velocity is pi
so it'll be minus pi on two radians per
second
okay okay so you've got to be really
careful about
like it can get confusing if you think
oh you know
if if you mix these two together and you
don't distinguish between them as
constant
versus um variable
right a common error would be to say
okay well when
when theta dot is pi then this will
become pi on two
so then the angle should be pi onto
minus pi on two
which is zero right so you're like wait
that that can't be
the rate of change can't be zero because
it is the angle is changing as you go
around
so the answer is you have to distinguish
between these two remember that velocity
is just about the part that's changing
okay